I honor President Obama you talked to
you recently
you got to meet it he told you that you
did the best impression of him he did
anybody he did that was crazy I couldn't
even believe that he saw our show right
key and Peele enough key and Peele fans
yes he he saw the show and he wanted to
meet you guys wanted to meet us very
specifically and it was crazy we got to
meet him it was a we're we're doing okay
well we so remember when he was in town
for that Clooney thing oh yeah I was at
that yeah you were anyway yeah nor were
us yeah nor were we
Indy and I were parking cars anything
when you're going to meet the president
no he's like you're looking for the
security or like these guys are gonna be
everywhere these guys gonna be
scrutinized and you don't see anything
and that's what and you'd like you look
to your left and you realize this like
the little old lady in the corner is
like eyeball and you're like oh they're
secret that they are they're actually a
secret security he's guarded by little
old ladies this guard is guarded by a
gang and entourage of little old women
yes like so they bring you I guess they
bring you to his hotel room and then
what's that meeting like I mean what you
know so yeah they bring in the meeting
and so you know first he comes up to hey
yeah you know because I need Luther I
need Luther that Luther was that anger
translator on needle which was awesome
yeah by the way yeah that he would
actually validate he's referencing your
skin yeah Luther they'll have to wait
we'll have to wait till second term you
know so he say he said he's a very funny
guy and it's very hard to like you cuz
he's the you know he's like commander in
chief and the other guard I'll put that
there and you know he's he's like
commanding the room but at the same time
you know he's got this slide little you
know smile on the corner of his eyes
sorry cuz you know uh Michelle likes the
show Michelle's a fan key and Peele
if she likes it you know what song you
know so you just get the impression that
she really is the most powerful person
in the world she's running him and then
he's running and she's got the remote
and did he do a little he did a little
physical comedy with you did and he did
a bit you know he check this out because
this little weekly addresses you know
struggling salad I do a pretty good
impression of myself he says this to me
yeah so he sits down he's doing his
weekly addresses and he gets something
and it's throwing it he's like it was
during this point with the the Secret
Service had their little scandal and
everything so he's like I'm keeping the
the security on their toes he goes you
know I got something in my throat
he points to one of his aides this woman
who's just standing right there and
she's got a bottled water he goes do we
trust her we trust her it's ridiculous
ridiculous like should not be joking
about this
that's very funny guy so you guys like
this he goes like this guard thank you
no all right no I'm just kidding Oh
gotcha it's a crazy thing crazy that
happens great and then so at the end he
was like alright well you know bank
thanks for meeting me Gus and I hate the
next season don't let me do anything too
crazy yeah we have a nice we have a nice
picture of you guys with the president
glad to see you've dressed up that my
mom hates my mom hates that I dressed
like a 1990s slacker always but in me
when you're meeting the president United
States